many survivors have drawn what they
experienced on
august 6 1945. that day
75 years ago the united states released
a nuclear bomb
that exploded approximately 600 meters
above the city of hiroshima
ninety thousand to one hundred twenty
thousand people
died from the blast three days later
nagasaki was bombed taking the lives of
another sixty thousand to seventy
thousand
people died instantaneously from the
intense heat released by the bomb
and in the following days weeks and
months from injuries and acute radiation
sickness
the survivors of the bombings came to be
called ibaksa
literally survivor of the atomic bombs
kuniko ira is one of them he was in
hiroshima when the bomb
fell
down
[Music]
[Music]
soon after the bombings japanese and
american researchers
went to the destroyed cities with
different objectives
the japanese focused on the bomb's
medical effects on survivors
the americans wanted to understand how
people died from radiation
which could be useful during future
nuclear wars
in 1947 the u.s formed the atomic bomb
casualty commission
or abcc to conduct long-term studies of
the victims of the bombings
in 1975 it was reorganized and renamed
the radiation effects research
foundation
or rerf one hundred twenty thousand
hibachia were enrolled in studies that
would track their health for many
decades
the u.s chose not to provide medical
treatment to the survivors of the
bombings
as it felt this could be seen as an
admission of fault
[Music]
i think you know human dimension or
humanity side has been the second
thing for this institute especially
when this started highlight is the way
science being conducted really
meticulous
and very slow and very well considered
scientists use detailed methods to
measure radiation
and understand its impact on survivors
a major focus of the research was
determining how much radiation
survivors were exposed to which depended
on their distance from ground zero
what type of building they were in and
even the positioning of their bodies in
relation to the explosions
over the course of decades the lifespan
study allowed scientists to determine
the links between
radiation dose and cancer risk and the
findings have helped establish global
limits for the maximum dose of radiation
people can be exposed to for instance in
medical settings
all the lay people go to the hospital
for diagnosis
is many are getting benefit from
survivors
so to say so they their
contribution to the world i mean
survivors contribution to the world is
really great we have to follow
the survivor to the last member
and that means you know we will be
compiling
the life long history of
experience of atomic radiation
biological samples taken from 30 000
participants over seven decades
await genetic analysis which could help
pinpoint
radiation's effect on molecules in the
body
we still do not have any direct evidence
that
okay yeah this cancer has so and so
mutation and which is characteristic to
radiation-induced mutation
so we can conclude this cancer
is mutated at so and so location
of the genome in 2017
niwa presented a plaque of appreciation
to those who participated in the
research
expressing regret that they weren't
offered treatment
you really have to take consideration of
humanity side of human dimension
otherwise science means nothing to them
or maybe negative thing to them
the only thing you can do is
have connection personal connection
individual connection to whatever the
person you are dealing with
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]